allez direction de la cité royale de
loches à présent hors oppose agnès sorel
favorite officielle dans ris est la dame
de beauté était aussi une femme de
pouvoir qui a pesé sur son époque une
influence euse avant l'heure en somme
titre de cette nouvelle exposition qui
lui est consacrée théodore de queiros
nous fait la visite
c'est l'histoire d'une jeune picarde âgé
tout juste de 21 ans lorsqu elle gagna
le coeur du roi charles vii 7 c'est
aussi le nombre d'années qu'il sufit à
agnès sorel pour marquer l'histoire
personnages contrastés brillante à la
cour elle fut longtemps jalousé pour son
statut de favorite agnès sorel ne passe
pas inaperçu et cela irrite elle était à
la fois très brillant sur le plan
intellectuel sur le plan de l'esprit
c'est une femme une femme tout à fait
éblouissante pour son époque et donc ça
crée des jalousies saccadé tension et et
on revient que finalement dans l'univers
qui est issu de la cour de france 15e
chaque été plutôt une cour 1 j'allais
dire qui avait été marquée par les
épreuves de la guerre de cent ans elle
apporter un nouveau souffle un souffle
que cette femme d'influencé expire pour
la dernière fois à seulement 28 ans mais
son image se diffuse prémices d'une
légende en gestation
vous voici dans cette salle où est
présente et donc le diptyque de melun
avec ses dires l enfant panne par jean
fouquet alors c'est la vierge qui
représentait mais sous les travers et
sorel en tout cas c'est une probabilité
forte et il est tout à fait innovant
pour l'époque puisque
il présente de nouveaux atours donc là
on a par exemple cette robe avec cela
sage singulier conduit à la gourgandine
qui dévoile la poitrine au fil des
siècles son nikon divisé fait l'objet
d'une succession d'oeuvre tantôt
représenté comme la séduisante
maîtresses qui détourna le roi tantôt
comme une femme vertueuse à l'image de
jeanne d'arc qui concouru au
renforcement du pouvoir royal ici à
loches son histoire imprègne les murs la
favorite y résident aux côtés du roi
elle qui repose toujours à quelques pas
sous la voûte de la collégiale